eux tout aussi mais ce n'est pas le
virus en cause la fermeture envisagée de
leur piscine celle de Chinon pendant
quatre mois cet hiver la communauté de
communes qui en a la gestion veut faire
des économies devant un coup de
l'électricité multiplié par 4 une
fermeture qui fait grincer quelques
dents chez les nageurs Audrey Chantepie
avec plus de 1200 signatures sur sa
pétition le club de natation de Chinon
espère bien échapper à la douche froide
voir sa piscine fermée cet hiver et une
partie de ces quatre sans licenciés
quitter le navire un adhérent vous le
détenez pas un adhérent s'il doit faire
15-20 kilomètres supplémentaires par
jour c'est compliqué c'est un budget
dans un contexte inflationniste et ça
malheureusement et je veux bien le
comprendre la Communauté de Communes le
prend pas en compte
pourquoi parce que ça la concerne pas
mais ça aussi il faut le globaliser dans
l'étude et se dire voilà c'est quoi
l'incidence vis-à-vis du citoyen et pas
seulement pour le pour seulement le club
de piscine la solution proposée par la
Communauté de Communes transférée
temporairement toutes les activités
aquatiques en un seul lieu la piscine
d'avoine à 8 km de Chinon pourquoi ce
choix pour tenter d'éponger
l'augmentation du coût de l'énergie pour
exemple le prix moyen d'électricité pour
la piscine de Chinon était de 108.000
euros en 2019 il pourrait atteindre les
420 000 en 2023 on est à bassin de vie
de 25000 habitants pour garder on va
avoir 2 millions et demi de charges
supplémentaires à la Communauté de
Communes si on fait pas un effort pour
essayer de réduire les charges à
demander on fait pas lorsqu'on va
produire c'est de maintenir l'activité
pour tous les scolaires du territoire
maintenir pour tous les clubs alors ça
nous demande de réorganiser les horaires
donc on va va allonger les amplitudes
des horaires on va redéployer les
personnels d'un bassin vers l'autre mais
on va garder les mêmes ouvertures et
l'idée c'est que chacun est toujours
accès au service la fermeture éventuelle
du bassin intérieur de Chinon
interviendrait à partir du 29 décembre
jusqu'au 30 avril le vote en conseil
communautaire est prévu courant
descendre